[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on georgia martin's book
firing blood vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon iii
is reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion that attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the show is also the
key in the history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons
the targaryen civil war which divided
the entire kingdom
and launched a huge war that was fought
from 129 ac to 131ac
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens
brothers fought brothers dragons fought
the dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead one of the supporters of rhaenyra
was nettles
nettles was a dragon rider for a near
targaryen's faction during the dance of
the dragons
she was either a lover or bastard
daughter of daemon targaryen
or maybe even both nettles also known as
nettie
was a dragon seed and the first and
possibly the last dragon rider of the
dragon sheep stealer
neri was a small brown skinned girl with
black hair and brown eyes
this would make nettles the only
non-white dragon rider in the history of
westeros
although not the only female dragon
rider several women in rhaenyra's
faction including rhaenyra herself
are dragon riders the skinny girl had
crooked teeth and scarred nose
according to gildane she could not be
called pretty
narrows was foul-mouthed filthy and
fearless
nettles was a bastard of house targaryen
known as one of the dragon seeds
her exact parentage is unknown but she
did not resemble her targaryen ancestors
instead she was notably dark skinned
like a summer islander
according to mushroom nettles was a
bastard of uncertain birth
she grew up homeless in spicetown and
hull on the island of driftmark
according to septeneustas the girl's
nose was slit after she was caught
thieving her cunning and intelligence
was best evidence in how she managed to
claim her dragon
as the great civil war known as the
dance of the dragons progressed
rhaenyra targaryen's faction which was
based on dragonstone
realized that they had more living
dragons than dragon riders
with 6 riderless beasts nesting on the
island
it's believed that only those of
targaryen blood can successfully bond
with and ride a dragon
so they proclaimed rewards for any
commoners on dragonstone
who could successfully bond with one of
the unclaimed dragons
specifically targaryen bastards and
descendants of targaryen bastards
who had been fathered over the years on
commoners of the island by young
targaryen princes
when he was decided by prince jacarys
valerian that the blacks needed more
dragon riders during the dance of the
dragons
several dragon seeds on dragonstone came
forward to answer the princess skull in
129 ac
many died or were injured by dragons but
then the 16 years of age
nettles was able to tame the wild dragon
sheepstealer
three of the dragons had known riders
before so they were claimed before too
long
but the other three were wild dragons
they had ground to adulthood never being
successfully claimed by
any rider at all and thus were unused to
the presence of humans
eventually many thought it was
impossible to bond with a wild dragon at
all
until nettles became the only one to
succeed when she bonded with the dragon
known as sheepsteeler
the basic descriptive name the commoners
of the island referred to him by
given that he had a taste for sheep from
their flocks
nettles realized that simply walking
right up to a while the dragon and
attempting to mount it was foolhardy
and had gotten many of the other dragon
seeds killed so she cleverly left a
fresh killed sheep every day for an
extended period of time
allowing sheep stealer to become
gradually used to her presence
nettles rode her dragon throughout the
rest of the war
her dragon sheep stealer was actually
one of the older and larger ones in the
dance
hatched when the old king was young
jaehaerys the first
meaning that he was at least 80 years
old and probably bigger than either
rainier's dragon cyrex or daemon's
dragon characters
he was described as being an ugly mud
brown color
for this reason not unlike nettles
herself previous targaryens had ignored
sheepstealer
preferring dragons with what they felt
were more beautiful colors
nettles participated in the massive
battle of the gullet
one of the largest naval battles in
history
nettles fought valiantly on behalf of
queen rhaenyra targaryen
in the battle of the gullet while her
fellow dragon riders hugh the hammer
and elf dwight celebrated after the
battle
nettles was upset by the death of
jacarys
during the fall of king's landing
nettles landed sheep's dealer on
visenya's hill
after the capture of king's landing she
accompanied rhaenyra's husband and uncle
daemon targaryen
with his dragon characters as they
hunted through the riverlands for prince
aymond targaryen
on the great dragon vagar who was
burning out the entire region in a
one-man one dragon private war
despite having the largest and greatest
living dragon alive however
aemond was at least wise enough not to
risk riding bergar into a two against
one fight
so he simply withdrew whenever they
neared and moved on to burn out some
other parts of the riverlands
while searching the riverlands for
prince eamon targaryen and vegard
prince daemon targaryen rhaenyra's
husband was constantly accompanied by
nettles
both in the sky and at their base made
him pool
according to mushroom daemon had come to
love the girl and took her as his
badmate
in contrast noren the maester at
maidenpool
stated the dragon riders had separate
bedrooms and the daemon doted up on
nettles as a man might
dote upon his daughter norin described
daemon teaching nettle's common
courtesies
and giving her fine gifts such as an
ivory hairbrush
a silvered looking glass a velvet and
setting cloak
and leather riding boots maidservant
said
daemon showed nettles how to wash
sharing a single tub at times
given that daemon was old enough to be
nettle's father
it's not impossible that she actually
was his best or daughter
and this is the reason they seem to have
unusually close bond
queen rhaenyra scored that red keep was
outraged by the treasons of tumbleton
done by elf and hugh
lady miseria long daymond spermore fed
the growing distrust of marine era
against the dragon seeds with rumors
about nettles and daemon's relationship
rainer now mistrusted all the dragon
seeds including the girl who rode with
her husband daemon
hunting amend in the riverlands she
ordered the girl's head
to be sent to her but there was a
complication as well as her dragon the
girl had taken to riding daemon
according to sam well according to
others damon simply took care of her as
if she was his own child
rhaenyra raged declaring that nettles
used spells to bond with sheep stealer
and to seduce the prince the queen sent
a raven to manford mutant
the lord of matempol requesting the
girl's head and ordering daemon to
return
to the capital manfred and his advisors
disobeyed however
when maestro noren informed daemon that
rhaenyra had declared nettles a traitor
daemon was disgusted and allowed her to
escape
after killing a large black ramp and
feeding it to her dragon
a tearful nettles flew sheepstealer into
the morning mists of the bay of the
crabs
the disappearance of nettle scene raged
rhaenyra
instead of returning to his wife damon
flew to harrenhal
where he issued a challenge to eamonn to
come and face him alone
both amend and the damon later arrived
at harrenhal
with their dragons and in the subsequent
battle above the godzivar both men and
both
the dragons perished since daemon's body
was never found in the god's eye
while amens was as well as their dragons
some
songs claim that he survived the
encounter and found his way back to
nettles
there are multiple theories about
nettle's fate that people in the world
of westeros believe
some believe that she rode out so far
over the sea that sheepsteeler was too
tired to fly back to land
and both the dragon and ryder drowned
nettles and sheep stiller were never
seen again
rumors abound however that this was just
a ruse to hide from rhaenyra
and in truth nettles later doubled back
to land
and the daemon miraculously survived his
fall into the god's eye lake
and the two lived out their days
together on the hidden isle of faces
this tale is popular among romantic
singers
some maesters believe that the burned
men originated from members of the
painted dogs who worshipped a firebitch
who would be nettles
and her dragon who would be sheepstealer
in a hidden veil after the dance
bringing gifts to the dragon woman and
displaying burns as proof of their valor
narelles reportedly spent her days in
the veil
then king aegon the second targaryen
regained the iron throne after
rhaenyra's death
there were reports that sheep stealer
had been seen at crack low point
and the mountains of the moon in 134 ac
during the reign of king aegon the third
targaryen sir robert
rowan led the royal army to the vale of
orento supports her job for iran
robert's men encountered sheep stealer
and ragged nettles in a cave
and in the ensuing fight sixteen men
were slain
and three score more were wounded
narrows and her dragon were last seen
flying deeper into the mountains of the
moon
there is no doubt that fire and blood
volume 2 will offer
certain answers to these questions when
the book is finally released
who knows maybe we even read about
legendary damon targaryen again who
might be alive and well with nettles
whatever the case nettles as a targaryen
bastard then the dragon rider plays an
important role in the house of the
dragon
and it will be interesting to see how
all the mysteries surrounding her will
be portrayed
from her heritage to her relationship
with daemon
to whatever happens with her later again
house of the dragon game of thrones
pretty cool based on house targaryen's
most exciting parts of history is coming
in 2022 on hbo
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comment section down below
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace